Shell's in California hi Michelle
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show how can
dr. John Bologna and I help thank you so
much for taking my call I really
appreciate it you guys sure yeah so here
is my question
um I often find myself beating myself up
for some of the stupid things I've done
in the past and I know you talked about
your rear view mirror in your windshield
so how do I park that in my rear view
mirror so it doesn't keep coming up I
want to do something that I learned from
David Kessler are you ready Michelle I'm
ready close your eyes and I want you to
picture a purple elephant
in your driveway you know you got it
there he's in your drive I got it in
your drive well you got a purple
elephant your driveway you got it yeah
alright so you have just proven to all
of America that you can control your
thoughts it's a choice and it's a
decision and I know that sounds trite
and it sounds easy and it was a
revelation to me a when I realized that
I get to decide the thoughts that I
ruminate on and I get to decide the
thoughts that I dismiss it was also a
revelation to me when I found out you
can get addicted to stress hormones and
you can get addicted to the chemicals
that rush through your body when you
have shameful thoughts in self-hatred
and self-loathing that can be a chemical
addiction that you got to work through
but at the end of the day you make a
decision I'm done beating myself up I'm
gonna treat myself like I just read
other people in my community do you
often Michelle let me ask you this do
you often talk to yourself in a way that
you would Bob somebody in the nose if
you heard them talking to the lady at
the cash register oh that's a good way
to look at it yeah so here's what I want
you to do starting today right now I
want you just to start being nice to my
new friend Michelle mm-hmm because she
has courage and
called into a couple of dudes she's
never met and said help and she's got
strength and she's kind and she did some
dumb stuff like we all did and starting
today you're gonna be nice to her yeah
be nicer to her than you would the lady
at the cash register for goodness sakes
that's a good I love that piano there's
a great picture most people talk to
themselves in a way they would never
talk to anybody else they're just mean
to them so yeah yeah right on it's true
yeah and it usually revolves around a
group of stuff we've done I mean I made
a brand out of my stupid stuff oh man I
even got started I made a career based
on my stupid stuff I did yeah I've got
I've got closets stapled shut because
the skeletons are banging to get out
right so yeah we're all near Michelle
and I think it's when mm-hmm
you decide I'm gonna stop being addicted
to the to the chemicals that that
flushed through my body when I think
about the dumb things I've done I'm
gonna start treating myself with the
same dignity and care that I treat
everybody else and then I'm gonna start
taking ownership of my thoughts and I
wish it was harder than that it's not
sometimes we need to go talk to somebody
sometimes we need to have a friend or
two or a group in our life that we can
lean on to say hey man I'm really being
mean to myself right now and they'll
just rattle your cage and say we'll stop
it because I like Michelle right but I
think it's that decision moment I'm done
being rude to myself I'm done being ugly
to myself I can't control my thoughts
and then you get connected with some
folks that are gonna hold you
accountable to that good word good